coastal areas from North to Central Peru
are in state of emergency dozens of
landslides have buried homes floods have
washed away Villages thousands of people
have been left homeless it is the rainy
season here but the Deluge is heavier
than usual climate experts say the
ocean's temperature in the North Coast
is at least one degree warmer they blame
that on a phenomena called El Nino and
they could spell more rain and mudslides
vulnerable and excessive rain continues
to use activating landslides and we
still have a month and a half left
a thing can happen
at risk are nearly 3 million peruvians
who live in Ravines and Riverbanks in
Commerce District the chiyon river has
washed away many homes frightened
residents are living Outdoors Elio
Hernandez says the government has
abandoned them where am I going to go we
live in precarious homes we want
retaining walls we need decent living
conditions
in 2017 a coastal El Nino cost more than
three billion dollars in Damages this
community was one of those washed away
Maria Elena Pena says they rebuilt in
the same spot because they didn't have
another option
we don't have money for a better home
that's why we've taken the risk of
living here we don't want to we have to
experts say climate change is making
these disasters more frequent
there are millions of peruvians who live
in barely habitable areas they build
their homes without permits but
authorities have done nothing to stop
them so others follow suit
nearly 10 percent of Peru's population
are at risk many complain the government
doesn't have a plan for them the state
doesn't have a social housing policy the
state implicity says I do not give you
housing but you can occupy the public
land you want from time to time I will
give you water and other services
is focused in tackling the emergency
experts say River drainage and
channeling systems must be built along
the coast but people like Elio say they
need urgent solutions for now his
community will have to hope they won't
become the next victims of the extreme
weather Mariana Sanchez Lima